so a big part of it is that materials we
chose so we chose very acoustically
friendly materials lots of foam or i
should say felt some foam cork stacked
materials at different sizes and
different i don't know how to put it but
they're stacked at different levels so
the sound reflects instead of bouncing
around and echoes and stuff like that we
get rid of that goes we have sound
insulated rooms that we do use when we
do need to talk to other people so we
have this idea of we do have an open
workspace so everyone has an open desk
but we also have these things called
team rooms and when two or more people
are talking we say go get a room you
know go get a room they go get a room
and the room is sound isolated so they
can have a conversation loud if they
want but not bother everyone else is
working and that's the big thing that's
really important about our space that we
do have places for people to get
together and talk but their sound
isolated and insulated so they don't
interrupt everybody else in space
think the modern sort of cool workplace
is the open loft wood floors everyone
out in the open collaborating all the
time are talking all the time and the
difference or the thing I think that's
important to keep in mind is that
interruption and collaboration are
different things and the modern
workplace with the open workspace and
lots of hard materials everywhere and
people cramped in to you know really
close to one another it just encourages
interruption it doesn't encourage
collaboration and so if you really want
to get creative and really want to work
on something you need uninterruptedly
time to get those things done and if
someone's calling your name you're
sitting really close to somebody else
it's very hard to actually find that
time and i think that the trait while
there's some good stuff about being able
to see people all the time and walk past
people and there's some nice stuff that
happens in those environments i think
that it should be more the exception
than the rule
the way we've kind of done is for the
past 10 years we've been writing on our
blog with a blog called signal versus
noise and we've been writing all of our
ideas down and sharing them with
everybody else because we figure if
they're valuable for us I'm sure
somewhere else could benefit from them
it doesn't cost as much to write these
things down we talk about them or write
them down internally so why not share
them externally too and so over ten
years we've been running down these
things about design and programming and
business and marketing and sales and all
the stuff that we have to do every day
and then we looked back on it and said
maybe we could turn all these blog posts
into a book maybe we can take the stuff
we've already written and turn it into a
book and polish it up and give it a
single voice but let's do that instead
so rework and getting real before it
which was our other book are not things
we sat down to decided and decided to
write there are actually things we sat
down and looked back and found the
things we've already written and then
compiled them together so these aren't
these aren't new ideas these are old
ideas these are ideas that we've tried
and we've tested and we put out there
and that's why I think the books are
valuable because they're not theoretical
they're not academic they're not in a
perfect world this is how it should work
it's actually this is how it has worked
for us and they're time-tested and
that's what we share them